.
Was passiert, wenn wir 100
Stunden lang wach bleiben?
Wie gefährlich ist Schlafmangel,
und wieso schlafen wir überhaupt?
Die Antwort gibt es heute
mithilfe eines guten Kollegen.
Das ist Masse, auch bekannt
als Techi von "Techtastisch".
Und bekannt für Experimente jeder
Art,darunter auch Selbstexperimente
zu Schlafentzug.
Bei meinem Selbstexperiment habe
ich die letzten 7 Tage jeweils
nur 4 1/2 Stunden geschlafen.
Wenn ihr sehen wollt,
wie YouTuber sich selbst zerstören,
seid ihr hier genau richtig.
Heute bleibe ich 60 h wach und habe
dadurch noch mehr Halluzinationen
und vor allem noch wirrere.
Und wer Techi kennt, weiß, dass es
nur eine Frage der Zeit war...
Dass ich dann irgendwann auch mal
den 100-h-Schlafentzug durchziehe.
Also Freunde der Sonne, wenn
ihr bereit seid, setzt euch.
Wer im Schichtdienst arbeitet,
gerade ein kleines Baby hat
oder gerne mal eine Nacht
durchfeiert, der weiß,
Schlafmangel ist grausam.
Warum Techi sich das freiwillig
antut, ist eine Geschichte,
die hier erzählt werden soll.
Kurze Antwort: Weil er verrückt ist.
Aber warum müssen wir eigentlich
schlafen, warum müssen wir uns
in diesen seltsamen Zustand begeben,
wo wir bewusstlos herumliegen,
uns völlig angreifbar machen,
warum reicht es nicht,
dass wir uns einfach nur ausruhen,
ohne gleich bewusstlos zu werden,
die Antwort
ist ziemlich interessant,
aber vorher müssen wir
erst mal verstehen:
Von außen ist es gar nicht so
leicht zu unterscheiden,
ob jemand wirklich
schläft oder nur so tut.
Von außen kann es sogar schwer sein,
ob jemand noch wirklich wach ist,
oder wirklich schon schläft.
Misst man jetzt aber die
Gehirnswellen einer Person,
dann kann man es ziemlich genau
sein, genauso ist Schlaf definiert,
über unser Gehirn.
Im Gehirn entstehen zu
jeder Zeit elektrische Felder,
die sich mit unserer
Hirnaktivität fortlaufend ändern,
diese Schwankungen kann
man messen, mithilfe von EEG.
Bei einer EEG-Messung bekommt
man eine Haube voller Elektroden
auf den Kopf, tut nicht weh,
sieht nur komisch aus.
Wenn man so eine Elektrode
anschließt,
dann bewegt sich
der Zeiger ziemlich schnell,
weil ziemlich viel
in dem Kopf passiert.
Das ist übrigens Lars.
Doktor Lars Dietrich genau genommen.
Ist es Schlafforscher und redet
gerne über seine Forschung.
Deswegen habe ich ihn angeskypt,
damit der uns u.a.
etwas über EEG erzählen kann.
Wenn die Leute einschlafen
wird der Ausschlag viel größer,
und regelmäßiger, dass es
vielleicht erst mal nicht intuitiv,
man denkt, der Ausschlag ist größer,
d.h. das Gehirn ist aktiver oder?
Was man später herausgefunden hat,
was passiert, ist,
das mehr Hirnzellen
gleichzeitig das gleiche machen,
deswegen wird der Ausschlag größer,
weil nicht mehr so viel passiert,
es macht nicht
mehr jeder seinen Kram,
sondern es ist ein
gemeinsames Wabern.
So nennt man das gemeinsame Wabern.
Und "Slow Way Sleep"
ist der tiefe Schlaf.
Schlafen heißt
also Ruhe für das Gehirn.
Aber nicht nur das:
Die große Überraschung war dann,
dass, wenn die Leute richtig
tief pennen, dass plötzlich das EEG
wieder aussieht, als wären die wach.
- Und das ist der REM-Schlaf?
Das ist der REM-Schlaf.
Unschwer zu erkennen
an "rapid eye movements".
Das ist die Phase in der man träumt,
typischerweise auch in der Phase,
wo man kurz aufwacht, sich umdreht,
die Decke zurecht zieht.
Das war so der große Durchbruch,
Schlaf es nicht einfach abschalten,
sondern da passiert sehr viel, u.a.
auch so viel Aktivität im Gehirn,
wie beim normalen Wachzustand.
Schlaf ist ein unglaublich
spannendes Forschungsthema,
Vieles ist immer
noch nicht bekannt,
oder wie Lars es
metaphorisch ausdrückt:
Wir wissen viel zu schlecht, was
das hier ist, wir wissen nicht,
wie das hier funktioniert, wir
wissen nicht, was der hier misst,
wir wissen nicht wie
das hier funktioniert.
Aber die Symptome von Schlafentzug,
die sind wohl bekannt.
Als sich Lars von Marcels 100-h-
Schalfentzug-Experiment erzählte,
gibt der folgende Prognosen ab:
Ich würde denken, dass
der ziemlich oft einfach dasaß
und ins Leere geguckt hat.
Viele Leute, die das gemacht haben,
haben angefangen, zu berichten,
dass sie optische Illusionen
hatten.
- Wie siehst du
da bitte eine Frau in dem Wasser?
Die Lust aufs Essen verändert sich.
Auch, wenn man nur eine Nacht
schlecht geschlafen hat,
hat man mehr Bock
auf süße, fettige Sachen.
Was auch schon anfängt, wenn einem
nur ein bisschen Schlaf fehlt, ist,
dass die Laune sehr stark leidet.
In einer Studie sollten
Versuchsteilnehmer die Attraktivität
von ausgeschlafenen und un-
ausgeschlafenen Personen bewerten.
Natürlich kamen die
Ausgeschlafenen deutlich besser weg.
Ich würde ganz gerne ein Foto
von ihm sehen am letzten Tag.
- Du wirst
Videos-Ausschnitte davon sehen.
Und natürlich gehen Aufmerksamkeit
und Reaktionszeit den Bach runter.
In der Forschung
gibt es ein Experiment:
Wo man im Prinzip einfach
nur vor einem Bildschirm sitzt,
und in unvorhersagbaren Abständen
kommt ein Signal, z.B. ein Punkt.
Dann musst du auf den Knopf drücken,
dass du den Punkt gesehen hast.
Diese Art von Aufmerksamkeit wird
bei Schlafmangel immer schlechter.
Wenn man nicht ausgepennt
ist und diesen Test macht,
fängt es damit an, dass
man einfach länger braucht,
bis man gedrückt hat,
dann hat man Leute dasitzen,
auf den Punkt wartend, den Finger
am Knopf, und dann kommt der Punkt,
geht wieder weg, und sie haben nicht
gedrückt und warten immer noch.
D.h. sie merken gar nicht,
dass sie verpasst haben, dass
der Punkt gekommen ist. - Krass.
Wenn dieser Punkt
jetzt ein Radfahrer ist,
und du gerade übermüdet im Auto
sitzt, dann ist das gar nicht gut.
Schlafmangel wirkt sogar nach-
weislich ähnlich wie Alkoholkonsum.
Was z.B.
die Reaktionszeiten betrifft.
D.h., Schlafentzug-Experimente sind
schon allein deshalb gefährlich,
weil man sich und
andere im Alltag verletzen könnte.
Bei Schlafmangel gilt außerdem, die
persönliche Wahrnehmung kann trügen.
Stellt euch vor, ihr nehmt
eine Gruppe von Menschen,
die normalerweise
8 Stunden pro Tag schlafen.
Jetzt lass dir diese Menschen
für eine Studie 2 Wochen lang
nur 6 Stunden pro Tag schlafen,
untersucht verschiedene Sachen,
erstens deren
subjektive Wahrnehmung:
Wie müde fühlst du dich, hast du
Kopfschmerzen oder solche Sachen.
Und zweitens könnt
ihr objektive Dinge messen,
wie z.B. Reaktionszeit
und das kommt dabei raus.
Sagen wir mal,
das hier sind 2 Wochen.
Die Striche sind völlig willkürlich.
- Ja, egal.
Grafiken zeichnen
ist eine Kunst für sich.
Jedenfalls, wenn ich jetzt
kontinuierlich Schlafmangel erleide:
Fühle ich mich die ersten 3 Tage
immer müder als noch den Tag davor.
Und irgendwann komme ich in
einem Bereich, wo ich denke, puh,
es geht mir ziemlich scheiße,
aber ich bin auf dem gleichen Level.
- Gleiches Level von Scheiße?
Ja. Es wird nicht mehr schlimmer.
Man gewöhnt sich dran. Glaubt man,
aber wenn man sich Dinge anschaut,
wie Reaktionszeit,
dann sieht das so aus:
Jeden Tag, den ich wieder zu wenig
schlafe, wird es immer schlechter.
Das geht immer weiter.
Während du glaubst, dass sich dein
Körper an den Schlafmangel gewöhnt,
ist die Realität, das dein Körper
einfach nur kontinuierlich abkackt.
- Wie siehst du da bitte
eine Frau in dem Wasser?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob ich
100 Stunden wach bleiben könnte.
Aber, die Tatsache, die Tatsache,
dass jemand wie Marcel das schafft,
scheint ja darauf hin zu deuten,
dass Schlaf nicht so
überlebenswichtig sein kann.
Deshalb jetzt noch
mal die Frage von vorhin:
Jetzt wird es wissenschaftlich.
Es ist höchstwahrscheinlich so,
dass es mehrere
Funktionen von Schlaf gibt.
Schlaf spielt für das Gehirn eine
wichtige Rolle beim Regenerieren.
Und beim Lernen. Es ist
schon etwas dran, wenn man sagt,
dass man über irgendetwas
eine Nacht schlafen muss.
Jede Körperzelle ist wie ein
Wunderwerk, mit lauter Mechanismen,
die ineinandergreifen,
und im Schlaf finden lauter
Instandhaltung-Prozesse statt.
Da wird zwischen den Zahnrädern
geputzt, da wird geölt,
da werden Schrauben nachgezogen.
Und die Schlafforschung
zeigt noch etwas Interessantes:
Das Gehirn braucht Schlaf,
um sich zu "entmüllen".
Leben bedeutet viele chemische
Reaktionen, sprich Stoffwechsel,
manche Stoffwechselprodukte brauchen
wir, andere fallen als "Müll" an.
Dieser Müll wird über eine Art
Leitungssystem entsorgt, das:
Der Körper hat also eine Art
Müllentsorgungssystem.
Das Verrückte ist, dass
das Gehirn so etwas nicht hat.
Das Gehirn, bzw.
das ganze zentrale Nervensystem,
ist nicht an dieses lymphatische
Entsorgungssystem angeschlossen,
doch auch im Gehirn passieren
ständig chemische Reaktionen
und auch dort fällt Müll an,
wie der entsorgt wird,
fand eine dänische
Neurowissenschaftlerin 2013 heraus,
indem sie Farbstoffe einsetzte,
und verfolgte, wie die sich
aus dem Gehirn heraus bewegen.
Vereinfacht könnt ihr
euch vorstellen,
dass der Müll des Gehirns
durch das Gehirngewebe
doch in das lymphatische Entsor-
gungssystem hineinsickern kann.
Da die Gewebezellen im Hirn,
die keine Nervenzellen sind,
Gliazellen heißen, nennt man dieses
gesamte Müllentsorgungssystem
des Gehirns glymphatisches System.
Eine Wortzusammensetzung:
Und jetzt das Spannende.
Diese Müllentsorgung passiert
im Schlaf etwa viermal so schnell
wie im Wachzustand.
Schlaf kümmert sich darum.
Jetzt kann man sich vorstellen,
wenn man jahrelang zu wenig schläft,
könnte sich durch die schlechtere
Müllentsorgung mit der Zeit
irgendwas Ungewolltes im Gehirn an-
reichern und zu Krankheiten führen.
Und Lars untersucht
genau das, er untersucht,
ob Schlafmangel
zu Alzheimer, Parkinson
oder anderen neurodegenerativen
Erkrankungen führen könnte.
Aber einmalig, für so verrückte
Schlafexperimente können Menschen
durchaus extrem lange wach bleiben,
scheinbar ohne bleibende Schäden.
Techi ist nicht
der einzig Verrückte.
Der derzeit offizielle
Rekord fürs Wachbleiben
liegt bei ganzen 11 Tagen!
Das Guinness-Buch der Rekorde
führt keine Einträge mehr
über Schlafentzug, um Menschen
nicht dazu zu motivieren,
denn bei einem sind
sich Experten einig:
Schlafmangel führt
zu erhöhtem Blutdruck,
und ein chronisch erhöhter Blutdruck
fördert Herz-Kreislauf Erkrankungen.
Schlafmangel wirkt sich auch
negativ auf unseren Blutzucker aus.
Und ein chronisch erhöhter
Blutzuckerspiegel
fördert Diabetes Typ 2.
Warum habe ich Marcel dann nicht
von seinem Experiment abgehalten?
Gut, weil er sich von
so etwas nicht abhalten lässt.
Stell dir vor, jemand
würde total viel Alkohol trinken,
oder jemand würde sich tagelang
nur noch von Zucker ernähren,
und nichts anderem. Dem würde
es richtig schlecht gehen,
je länger er das macht, desto
schlechter würde es ihm gehen.
Wenn er dann wieder zur Vernunft
kommt, das Experiment abbricht,
dann wird er ein
bisschen Erholung brauchen,
danach wird es ihm wieder gut gehen,
daraus kann man aber nicht
schließen, das Alkohol trinken
oder sich nur von Zucker ernähren,
keinen Schaden verursachen würde.
Das sieht man, wenn man
sich Leute anguckt,
die über Jahre oder
Jahrzehnte viel trinken.
Oder sich sehr schlecht ernähren,
da sieht man, dass es einen sehr
starken gesundheitlichen Effekt hat.
Und so sollte man sich meiner
Meinung nach auch Schlaf vorstellen.
So sollte man Schlaf verstehen.
Übrigens, wenn Lars jetzt
wissenschaftlich untersuchen wollte,
wie sich 100 Stunden Schlafentzug
auf den Menschen auswirken,
könnte das schwierig werden,
denn Lars vermutet,
dass er eine solche Studie
heutzutage an keiner Ethikkommission
vorbei kriegen würde.
Wissenschaftlich gesehen
ist Techis Experiment
zwar nicht statistisch signifikant,
aber dafür eine umso
wertvollere Fallstudie.
Wenn ihr also sehen wollt,
wie es ihm ergangen ist:
Schaut euch doch mal mein Video
dazu an, da verrate ich auch,
mit welchen Mitteln man
das überhaupt schaffen kann.
Zwei Tropfen reichen.
Ich verlinke ich euch das, denn
das hier war ja nur die Theorie.
Die Praxis in voller Länge
und mit allen Halluzinationen
und allem drum und dran gibt
es dann bei "Techtastisch".
Für mich nehme
mit aus diesem Video,
dass Schlaf und Schlafforschung
unglaublich spannend ist
und dass ich früher oder später
noch ein Video dazu machen muss,
weil wir hier jetzt nur ein
paar Basics anreißen konnten.
Das heißt, wenn euch irgendwas zum
Thema Schlaf besonders interessiert,
schreibts in die Kommentare, dann
kann ich es nächstes Mal aufgreifen.
Und wir sehen uns in der Endcard.
Pssst!
Wusstet ihr, dass ich auch
bei Instagram und Twitter bin?
Das könnte interessant sein
für alle Freunde der Sonne,
die gerne wissen wollen,
was diese Mai außerhalb
von YouTube noch so macht.
Und hier kommt ihr auch
zum Video von "Techtastisch".
Schaut da bitte rein und
hinterlasst dem Marcel
doch ein paar Klicks und Emojis.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche
dann wieder am Donnerstag.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2018)